you're
listening to the dollop on the all
things
comedy network this this is a bi
american history podcast where each week
i
dave anthony elect men and women read a
story from american history
to my friend gareth reynolds who has no
preference either will go either way who
has no idea what the topic is going to
be about
uh here we are we're back in the studio
weird
it is weird isn't it it's progressive
you feel uncomfortable i do
i feel is it because you're looking into
my blue eyes yeah you've got those
steely
blue eyes and the rum smell is
strong from that direction yeah um i
picked up the rum smell over uh over
the lockdown are you doing rum sense the
new
scent from rum yeah yeah i'm home
home brewing you're home rumman i'm home
you have a rum tub
yeah i have a that's right yeah i i was
looking at a house that had a rum
oh the rum tubes are great they're great
very uh very like 1800's
stained there's yes the smell is
dead in the rum tub um but yeah it is a
little weird
it's all weird you know what though you
know who loved who who loves a rump tub
oh we're dogs
yeah for sure yeah so that's where
the dog came from that's right um but
uh it is weird it's
the we're in the weirdest phase of this
thing
where i'm like
i've thought everyone was crazy the
whole time but now you're just like
like everyone's crazy
everyone is in charge it's crazy it's
crazy
out of their minds and just saying
things that are just like true
not true not true at all everyone
it turns out that a pandemic is the
greatest
gaslighting that can ever happen it's
like it was like we
it's like america's a computer and we
ran a diagnostic
and we're so full of viruses that we're
like we need a new laptop this is just
like not functioning anymore
this whole thing is [ __ ] yeah that's
right
anyway dave uh on that note travel's
still happening
uh i will be on the road i want people
to come to see my
stand-up shows i will be at comedy on
state where i recorded my
first and most recent album riddled with
disease uh july 22nd through the 25th
comedy on state madison wisconsin
then in phoenix arizona i'll be at cb
live august 5th
i'll be at the rally improv august 6th
through the 8th
uh in north carolina i'll be at hyenas
in dallas on august 19th august 20th the
state theater austin texas
august 21st the rec room in houston
texas august 26
spokane comedy club in spokane
washington
and tacoma comedy club august 27th you
can go to garethreynolds.com for all
those tickets
and then we are still going on tour in
australia
uh hey guys get it together
let's no more going out till we're there
that's the deal
uh and you can go to uh
dolloppodcast.com for all those dates
we'll be going to all our
usual hubs melbourne sydney adelaide
canberra
we'll be hitting new zealand uh and
there's some others in there too
there are some others there's some
others yeah yeah but go
dollapodcast.com get tickets australia
and uh mask up and quit going out and
and uh
maybe get a new person to run your
country who knows
that's right get a new person around
your country maybe the first move before
we get there
that would be great that would be great
if you could get morrison
moving along and we'll be at the would
you say the high plains comedy no i
didn't we'll be in
september we'll be there go to
dollarpodcast.com it's all there and
then we'll be announcing new uh u.s
states very very soon that's right
so buckle up everyone uh we're brought
to you in part by
paint your life now uh i've heard about
paint your life
and uh com as they call it and i thought
what a
it's an interesting idea that's a very
interesting idea it's got to be really
expensive turns out
not that expensive so here here's what
you get
uh you go to paintline paintyourlife.com
there's a bunch of different options you
get a professional hand-painted portrait
it's created by any photo any photo it's
very affordable they have a team of
world class artists
and you work with them until every
single detail
is exactly how you want it very user
friendly
right it lets you order a custom made
hand-painted portrait in less than five
minutes
and now gareth
went ahead and did it yes dave go ahead
and tell us about your experience
when selecting which picture of myself
to get painted i was torn
so i went with one of jose of course and
i'm
very pleased uh it is awesome
and it is very easy the it is like a
legit painting like
you see brush strokes you feel like this
has been painted for you and that's a
nice feeling
yeah uh and i just got out of jose
you'll see it
on the latest episode of pandemics with
my mother i've got it now featured
prominently behind me yeah but uh
yeah it's super easy you literally just
upload a photo
then they go back and forth with you two
or three times basically being like you
sure
this look good for you are you happy
with this and then you confirm it and
then it comes in a frame
and you have a painting of your animal
or your human depending on if you find
love in your species or outside of it i
personally have had to
leave my species to find the connection
that is keeping me going and it's with a
feline you're weird and it's not okay
no and um and uh yeah but it is awesome
i was like i was genuinely i mean my
face when i opened it i was like sure oh
my god this is awesome
all right so uh at paintyourlife.com
there's no risk if you don't love the
final painting your money is refunded
guaranteed and right now as a limited
time offer get 20
off your painting that's right 20 off
and free shipping
to get this special offer text the word
dollop to
64-000
that's dollop to 64-000 text dollop
to 64-000 paint your life celebrate the
moments that matter
most terms apply available at
paintyourlife.com
terms again text dollop 264-000
good stuff man yeah i'm gonna have to
i'm gonna have to do that
uh myself you were very gracious i did
let you have it you let me have it
normally
these are things i don't even find out
about until we do the ad that's right
because i do all the work
i do a lot
i have to show up cold it's not easy
november 6 1908 a year
of our lord jesus christ
you know one of the wise men brought rum
sense i know
oh i know the fourth wise man not a lot
of people hear about the fourth wise man
they dipped they dipped the baby in
jesus in rum a lot and they just go
ahead
that was what christening that was how
people used to drink liquor back then
they didn't correct
the baby in it baby come on i'll do
another yes
i suppose i'll be baptized again i'm not
driving
[Music]
vincent and nat tyquits sure
pleasure let's just hope that's it that
could be
natokowitz he was born in trenton new
jersey his father worked in a factory
uh his dad only spoke polish okay
when vince was young he would go
shopping with his father to make sure
star owners didn't take advantage of him
because he didn't speak that'll be a
million dollars you know you'll go
one two three i'm low is that polish
i don't know
i was just hoping it was see this is
where the hard work for me comes in yeah
you think this is i'm trying not to find
what i would call it half-ass
yeah thank you uh that's what i trade
for
it's a good student he was very very
good at math
but he drops out after the eighth grade
you know okay why not it's the early
1900s sure that's pretty good
uh his mother died when he was 13. do
you imagine how great it would be to
drop out in eighth grade
if i was allowed to drop out in eighth
grade i mean i know it seems like i did
but uh but i didn't and man would i have
given the option presented with the
option before going high school
yeah i'd assign anything i could do it
all over again i would get my ged early
yes yeah yes uh so his mom dies when
he's
uh he's 13. okay his dad remarries
vince and his older brother charlie his
older brother i had i
some things said it was his brother
there was an article in the paper that
said it was his stepbrother so i
i i'm not sure whatever okay
um but they didn't like their stepmother
so i assume it's not his mom but it
could be his mom he might not like his
mom
sure i don't like your mom i love my mom
what are you talking about vince would
often run away
and hole up in abandoned factories okay
like any
13 year old sure yeah just what you do
absolutely yeah
uh the state at this time paid a bounty
if you told me that i could drop out of
eighth grade
yeah and live in a factory there's i
mean literally
it would have been i'd have been like
yes and and honestly there's
so many abandoned factories in america
like that's almost like that's not true
to bite your tongue sir you could just
fill them with 13 year olds
well i think we're getting back to where
the story starts now
you know just fill the factories with
teenagers and then get them washing
stuff that's an idea right nobody's ever
done that
so the state of new jersey this time was
paying a bounty for groundhogs
and uh this country is just phenomenal
it's just it's just every it's
everything it's everything you want and
don't want
it's just the greatest biggest [ __ ] pile
ever
it's amazing this country's like a mcrib
you shouldn't be eating
it's just too delicious to stop i always
just think about how this
there's a groundhog bounty no america
was just that's a throwaway line in this
it has a groundhog bounty america was
just an animal holocaust like the
beavers
the squirrels the groundhog we still are
though i mean
with the way that we are still pushing
our parameters further and further like
we obviously don't give a [ __ ] but now
it's
less it's now less because they're pests
and it's more because of capitalism but
back then it was just like there was
always this
public enemy number one animal vermin
yeah like critter whatever it was
whatever it was and it was just it was a
big festival to just go and murder the
things yeah just that
the winner gets to eat them all you know
whatever it will just have them
or just have them or no win pelts you
could do
groundhog pelts yeah make yourself a
nice groundhog jacket sure you know this
is made from
800 groundhogs this long coat
some are still living yeah so uh
charlie and uh vince spend the summer
trapping groundhogs
okay then they also started trapping
muskrats and otters near
lake carnegie okay when vince was 17
he got a job working construction they
were building the pulaski skyway
he also this time had an affair with a
married woman okay
how old is he he's 17. okay she breaks
his heart
and she goes back to her husband right
uh vince's sister quote
that was the day he also smashed up the
family car
so he had a rough that was a rough one
sure he had a rough day okay so
so it's tough it's as hard to date
married people
yeah yeah so as as happens in these uh
situations he uh
it's called pulling a g graphic it's
like i'm gonna get the [ __ ] out of here
okay what's it called
component geographic okay uh that's new
right
what the term geographic no it's an old
term
you just haven't heard it but that's a
term i dropped out in eighth grade
so vince his best friend john dykas
and charlie started hopping trains so
they're doing the hobo
business sure they cross the country
they're trapping as they go the traffic
this is the story of hoboken
that was good thank you proud of you
yeah my jokes must be bad because the
last two episodes
are we allowed to do that now yeah okay
shaking hands uh oh i have covet oh i do
too
um i have a better one i have delta oh
that's good
yeah so they're tr
as they travel they would stop they get
off the train they'd trap
they'd sell the hides and then keep
going so that's how they're making their
money on the trip
all right uh and they're also gambling
they're doing a little playing some
craps in the
cars which are just standard of course
you have to is there an easier place to
roll dice
than a moving train i can't think of one
nope oh
snake eyes wait seven so vince seemed to
be alone when this happened but he
he's down near the border he crosses the
rio grande as he's setting traps
okay so he's in mexico now mexico's in
the middle of a civil war
they see this dude because they're like
here's a
gringo is he selling guns because a lot
of people are going down there selling
guns so they just arrest him
right by the way that should be the
policy when a strange white man comes to
your town from now on 100
100 arrests then ask some questions then
evaluate always arrest
yes so rest first and then evaluate so
they didn't have any evidence on it but
they put him in jail and he's in jail
for weeks but he is
he's a big dude he's 220 pounds six feet
two
okay and he eats like [ __ ] crazy what
does
you mean he eats a lot he eats so much
food okay and
after a while he's eating so much food
though like we cannot afford to keep
this guy i like
the idea that a prison is like he wants
more it's like it's not like oliver
like you know what i mean like just i
mean he's your prisoner
i think you're in the power position to
be like yeah yeah we're not gonna give
you another sandwich but instead like
manny
he wants more baloney so uh i don't know
what we're gonna do let's let him go
i think he's like a walrus human so they
release him
more chum vince
[Applause]
he'll eat him raw he loves them he's
like a bear
so now he's on his own his it sounds
like they released him because of how
much he
they couldn't afford to feed him so joey
chestnut goes to jail
that he's able to get out in the city oh
yeah yeah yeah he ate through the bars
he's a real champion he chewed through
the wall he's a real champion
i'm an american hero that's an american
hero um so he
so vince uh sorry charlie and his buddy
uh john dykes are
back they go back to new jersey i don't
know what happened there but okay
so he goes california and he tries
trapping in the mojave desert
and that doesn't work pretty soon he's
broke he's starving he has nothing
he's not finding a lot of life in the
desert no weirdly
weirdly uh so he goes back to trenton
and
pretty soon the three dudes once again
hop a train and they head southeast
and this time they end up in jupiter
florida
in september 1931. it's great that we've
got a planet city
in florida of course well jupiter is now
my my uncle was a huge drug dealer this
is saturn michigan
if you've been here it's got the rings
my uncle john was a huge drug dealer
and he ended up in jupiter florida
like living across the canal from burt
reynolds like it's a very
rich super fancy community now but right
now
he looked like he was from jupiter he
did didn't he but back then it was just
uh very not very populated just wild
sort of florida there's like 300 people
living there okay
um so that's what they end up and
charlie mintz decided when they got
there that they should have a new last
name because their last name was too
complicated people couldn't say it
you you included yeah of course uh
and they picked nelson okay much easier
is this the story of nelson the twin
singers
yeah god i've never wanted to hear this
uh vince quote it just seemed to me that
if people have a hard time pronouncing
your name you ought to do something
to make it easier for them and let's can
we just
bottom line this as the immigrant
american experience thank you
just um we've bludgeoned you into
shame no longer i'm sorry i can't say
your name can you change that
uh yes i am jacobs i'm actually on the
side
i'm on the side of changing the name to
make it easier to say it's well
of course you are yes i mean my name was
changed so why shouldn't everybody else
what was your name
uh there's two versions one is o'neill
but um
i know but they they used the first name
of one of the
people as the last name i don't know oh
so just like it became anthony
okay doesn't seem that complicated don't
worry about it
okay well they didn't want to be irish
because being irish here was a nightmare
but not at all
they set up uh they set up so they set
up a very crude hunting and trapping
camp
okay they bore a well they built the
lean too
i had a dream i boarded well recently oh
yeah we all do we it's a very common
dream
okay it means you're a [ __ ] idiot i
went well it wasn't well well
so bessie dubois and i think john dubois
they they own a local restaurant
uh-oh quote one night this scrawny
fellow and the very muscular
vince were eating dinner at the same
table it's like jake and ellwood
they asked what was for dessert my
grandmother brought out a large lemon
meringue pie
the little guy sliced off a sliver and
vince peace i'll have the red he
garfield did it he ate the rest of the
pie he did like garfield
yeah well then you got to do the thing
where you take the one slice and then
you take the rest
thank you he did yeah that but you got
to do it first you've got to do it to
garfield
yeah that is phenomenal okay so are we
i'm hoping that we're in the early
stages
of the eater's story i mean there's a
lot of eating
there's definitely eating that happens
okay so
um as a little bit of tension between
the three guys
and one morning vince goes out trapping
and charlie wakes up
and he comes out and he tells dyches
that he's leaving and he wanted quote my
share of the business
okay uh and he wants it now
easy to do for sure well we have a bank
here so that'll be my problem too
dull that out diego says well i'm only
going to give you give you 50 bucks
and charlie quote i told dice he had 15
minutes to give me my fair share or i
was going to kill him
it's it feels sudden to me because it
escalated i
felt like we and then one morning your
friend wakes you up and says you have 15
minutes to give me my share i kill you
yeah and that and that's the share
you're saying is not enough well
yeah right yeah no who needs coffee when
you wake up to that
so dyke is responded by just he just
kept cooking he's like okay whatever
charlie then got his shotgun said time's
up and shot dice in the head what was
like
dykus so dykus clearly did not take this
he was not taking any seriously he
should he should have taken it more
seriously because
he doesn't have a head now yeah i would
certainly
if you were in that situ and again it's
dark this is a dark point
this is yeah that's the dark point i'm
about to make but i would wait for the
breakfast to be done cooking and then
i'd shoot him so then i could just sure
that makes sense hey i got a plate of
food
but again he wasn't really thinking yeah
no he just very spontaneous
so i it's gonna be strange when he comes
back from his little trapping expedition
well you know i didn't even
be like i didn't find anything about
that what i found was that charlie then
got in his car drove
15 miles to the west palm police station
walked in told the death sergeant he
just killed a guy named john dicas
and then he wrote a confession and in
the confession he said quote
finally i just had enough
would be great if we just went back to
this system of murder turn yourself in
yeah
yeah way easier so so what vince is
going to come back to is going to be
a very strange yeah well i i assume
there's nothing about what vince found
but he must have come back and just yeah
well this is one guy's dead and one
guy's gone
this is not how i left that and
breakfast is ready unbelievable what
great news
oh my god canadian bacon
so they arrest vince also charlie and
vince are both well he'll be out
he'll be out in two days we're out of
bread sir we don't know what to do
anymore
he's a whale man so charlie pleaded not
guilty
uh vince gets out charlie plitt not
guilty yeah i don't understand
how you write that confession to murder
and then go but i didn't do it
i mean if you're writing in a confession
well i just had enough you're
done yeah it's so [ __ ] done uh your
honor uh
i still didn't kill him yeah i mean i
was just uh you know
up to up to here up to my eyes so i just
i killed him i plead not guilty your
honor that is uh
shut him in the head completely innocent
i didn't do it
so i'm gonna find the fella who did
though it's me
case closed not guilty uh
charlie did regret killing him but he
told the reporter quote but what
good does it do to cry about it
i mean i guess not guilty considering
his emotional state is the right plea
because it's i mean it's not how you
plea it's how do you feel
not guilty he but he sounds like he
would have rather have pled
who gives a [ __ ] yeah ah yeah can i
plead who gives a [ __ ] your honor
no you cannot okay uh
what about there's two options really
any who's will be no
then by the way that one's copy written
so back off of that one right away that
is
yeah this shirt i've heard that from
other people
uh so they have a trial and at the trial
charlie breaks down and cries during the
testimony it was prosecution like this
is really fun
yeah like he confessed to it he's crying
it's pretty much a layup
and then vince testified and he
testified against
his brother uh charlie said vincent told
him to leave the camp
and that he was shocked but he agreed to
and that he didn't really remember the
killing
and then vince testifies dikes was doing
all of his share of the work and charlie
was the guy who was the slacker
bad guy lame and the problem right
charlie gets life in prison at the
sentencing he told vince he would come
back
and kill him and then he told the judge
the same thing okay so that's
by the way if you get life in prison
it's time to have a little fun on the
way out of the court no if you get life
in prison
it's it's a it's a free pass to say
whatever you want anything you want i'm
gonna kill that judge i'm gonna suck his
neck blood okay take him away i will eat
your guts your honor i will eat your
guts all right
i'm gonna eat your guts i'm gonna love
it i'm gonna video it i'm gonna save
your family and since
spaghetti's the email subject okay well
you're going to jail yeah you two
i eat you and everyone important to you
okay
go ahead and take him away he is going
to jail for life
goodbye apparently you don't understand
what my cynthia
life in jail sorry i spent most of the
time talking about how it's going to eat
the judge's neck stringy gutty pieces
okay i love my son too
i really should have conceived this
better take care
uh yeah
i'm gone
so vince is now broke he's 24 he's alone
in florida
okay he goes back to new jersey for a
little bit uh he works on a farm but
then
he's like i like florida uh so he moves
back
and he pitches camp on the origin i'm
probably gonna say this wrong
of the luxahatchee river right
where the swamp feeds water into this
big
deep pool it's about 100 yards wide okay
my mind i'm thinking gilligan's island
sure for sure one guy one guy vincent's
island this is a nice
mm-hmm uh it's the place uh
it's the last place a motorboat can go
before on this on this river then then
you have to
switch to a right canoe or whatever
right
and then he changed his name okay
keeps the last name still nelson well
first let's be fair
to be fair he's picked the last name too
so first name
trapper trapper nelson trevor nelson
okay
so yeah he should have gone with keeper
[Applause]
trapper i mean you i told you the story
about how i want like
i wanted to be called spike when i was a
kid like i legally wanted to change
my name like seven and i was like
seven eight and i was furious when my
mother told me no
and i was like this is the more [ __ ]
the more you go through history
the more you realize how awesome
odd names are yeah right yeah like spike
reynolds
yeah wait name great [ __ ] name said i
got stuck with gareth you change it to
gary and my life's been a name hell ever
since
well that's your own that's your
completely orchestrated by you in every
way
you're fighting against the tides you
did everything to bring that upon me
you're going to drown
you're fighting against the tide that's
really all you're doing
okay spike the depression is now on
okay um he made money spearing fish
and selling them okay spear nelson way
better
yeah uh you know people are hungry and
they ate whatever they could catch
okay in this a friend quote we ate
manatee and sea turtle
the sea cow tasted like pork we ate sea
turtle
in steaks and soup it was against the
law but we had to live
right okay uh so then trapper
in this little plot of land that he is
rapper that he is
set up on nelson he plants a bunch of
fruit trees
okay including pineapples oranges i mean
it's tons of fruit trees
he built a very elaborate hand pumped
irrigation system
okay sets traps all over
author james snyder quote his aim was to
strike a sustainable balance
of raccoon otter and bobcat okay
possum and skunk came with the territory
as well and would fetch
lesser amounts gators he would catch
mainly for
food at first trapper nelson ate
everything from possum to catfish
to gatormate his favorite food was
gopher tortoise
stew oh my god wow a friend say
he ate everything except for buzzards
okay that's interesting um gators he
he sold this he sold the skin for shoes
and purses
for a raccoon pelt he'd get two dollars
and fifty cents that sounds about right
an alligator three dollars a worm free
otter pelt up to fifteen dollars we've
all learned a lot about otter pelts
which is disturbing
i love it baby this one's got worms too
so they're all over you
god damn it i love a nice just
warm-filled otter pellet
i like to know that the worms are i like
it's called the worm jacket that's right
and uh it's a warmer coat well you you
put them on and they scratch you
it's like oh it's great i love it when
they go through your skin and treat it
like dirt i call it a living jacket
it's awesome it is lovely look at my
back it's like
it's golf course for tiny balls it's
upsetting
he uh he also caught and sold rare
animals to zoos like he would catch
panthers and
sure i mean it wasn't it didn't happen a
lot but he he would right
it must be tough to not eat them uh he
built a pit for alligators and another
one for poisonous snakes
to trap them or to just just have him
around i guess okay
sure i mean the poisonous steaks you're
gonna want a pit of that uh you don't
want them running around
no no for sure in a pit yes and you
don't get rid of them you keep them near
you in
some sort of hole exactly because we all
know they can that's the best thing to
do
yes what could go wrong nothing uh vince
testified
sorry trapper uh sorry i moved
everything
down uh accidentally he went back to
so people start hearing
right no word is out that there's a
tarzan-like guy
living in the jungle well and we're off
and we're off
so oh society
what will you do now what weird [ __ ]
tarzan's really popular at the time oh
this is good
okay so people are like let's go get a
look at the tarzan guys so they get in
boats
and they're going up to see him at the
camp now he had a flock
of guinea fowl that lived in a tree near
his dock
and so whenever they started screeching
trapper understands yeah he knew people
he's one of the i mean he is a little
tarzan
it's a doorbell yeah right hey uh and
then he'd come out in his outfit
being hunting boots okay shorts
all right and a pith hat okey-dokey so
and that's it okay
well i mean i guess he's checking the
boxes that would be oh
i get to see it oh my god
jeez i mean i would go
check out this person yeah i mean he is
yeah why not i mean he's our crocodile
dundee
here's the here's the pith hat um
oh uh he sometimes wore a
bandana instead of the pith hat but
there's using the pith hat
oh yeah yeah you know it's odd because
it's just now it feels like pith hats do
need shirts now that i see it but look
look how ripped he is he is ripped he's
ripped ripped he's
got the he's got the the things what do
you call these down on the side
oh yeah yeah he's got those little like
pistol abs yeah the pistol lab things
like he's he's like there's dudes that
pay tons of money at the gym to look
like that yeah and all you need to do is
just put your brother in jail and have
birds be your doorbell
straight forward that's how you get your
abs oh it's very straightforward yeah
so uh so that's what he that's what he
comes out as
a vince is he's very good-looking uh-huh
very good-looking sure but he smelled
from all the killing and
and whatnot sure right of course he
he built he he kept his clean clothes in
a separate building
oh that's how you know you stink when
you have a different abode for the
wardrobe
that's how you know you have b.o i
should probably build another building
well i if i'm gonna have to change it's
gonna take a little while i gotta go to
my other property
that's why i keep my clothes i keep them
in the non-death non-death-smelling hut
you smell me right now right yeah it's
quite pungent isn't it terrible you
smell like a dead thing well i've been
rolling around in seawater with wild
animals all day
so it's not good but um what i would
suggest is give me 20 minutes
okay i'll go through my proper procedure
and then i'll go to the house that
doesn't smell like me
and i'll put on some clothes what about
bathing uh i'll be bathing once i go
into the house where my clothes are
because i don't want them to stink but i
want to be clear
i'm not bathing for any other reason
that i need to keep
that apartment sterilized completely
have you thought about just not
constantly killing animals so you don't
smell like death
i thought about it but that would really
change my lifestyle other people have
suggested maybe a fragrance
or something like that but again i think
that would worry the animals
i'm trying to get my pheromones give off
well it is pungent and strong
uh it for nature it's great i mean
that's how you get the birds to obey you
the
alligators to stay in their pits and the
you want to rip
nope you know some people say that you
could find the spirit molecule if you
smell my armpit i don't want to do that
give a rip
i don't take a couple puffs there you go
lay down lay down lay down lay down let
it happen let it happen
this is b.o ayahuasca lay down have the
vision
take the trip if you see a dragon with
keys take the keys go to the dungeon
open the door you have to get a golden
cube
you have to get a golden cube i always
see
darkness smell again take another rip
boy you'll finish the mission proper
oh god that's your balls oh yes i'm
sorry i really want you to find this
golden cube
get under there get under the
undercarriage
sniff the taint lad find the golden cube
erin you okay with all that yelling
that's him that's him yeah and the guy
on the left
of the left is a he was like a teenager
so teenagers would hang out there that's
always a cool guy and they were
always when a grown-up hangs out with
kids i'm always like this guy's cool
well all the kids like they liked it
because he was like he liked the kids to
hang out and jump and swim in the water
and like
the kids would have like competitions
who would go up the highest and like it
was just like a place of people anyway
whatever yeah
and there would be some scrutiny today
um so
he james snyder quote when author james
snyder he wrote a book about him
quote when dogs got downwind of him they
could
catch the scent of wild cat and bark
themselves hoarse
which embarrassed both trapper and the
dog owners
so so he just smelled like smelled so
much like an animal dogs were like we
found one
yeah he's like no that's me boy yeah
okay yeah interesting um he's very
friendly
everyone likes him he would show off his
animals
like i said he had the he had a barrel
filled with rattlesnakes as well as the
pit
um so that's just a rattlesnake that's
just a pure rattlesnake barrel then he's
got the snake pit
sure so sure to go he gets up every
morning and the first thing he does for
exercise is chopped firewood
he had to get a custom-made axe because
his hands are so
huge that he would break axe handles of
normal axes
he would have accidents um
wait so i i don't understand the hit
his his hands are so big that
and probably he's just so massive and
strong
but whatever it is about the handle he
because it comes up more than once that
his hands are gigantic
so he's just smashing so whatever yeah
so he's smashing axes
okay he's a bit of a bunion he would
drink water right out of the river he
would just walk over and put his face in
there they say you're supposed to
yeah that's where the any of those
parasites they're not dangerous
not at all uh and animals just follow
him around so he's got dogs to fall
around there's raccoons that fall them
around so it's just like a little
you know it's an interesting situation
it's an interesting situation
now people start coming to see him and
he would drape a big indigo snake
around his neck which i think i had a
picture of did i show you that
no you didn't show me the indigo snake
around his neck does that come from the
barrel or the pit do we know
oh i don't think i have it around his
neck i just show you the picture of him
with it
uh holding it um
no tha i don't think an indigo is uh
poisonous i might be wrong someone's
gonna for sure it was a live snake he
would put around his neck yeah it's a
live snake
different different than what i was
pictured um people would come up
and um to see him now people are coming
up in boats and they
and they'd bring um like a picnic and
then he'd eat
their food that's great that i want i
wouldn't mind getting there
they they would be like hey do you want
a sandwich and then eat the whole
sandwich like he was like
he would just devour everything he's
yogi bear yeah he's young
hey this picnic basket's empty i have no
idea what i did huh
but then he searches he says all these
people are coming so
oh there is a snake there oh he's got a
bobcat he's got he's holding a bobcat in
the jesus position yeah that's right
that's how they come that's
that's the jesus bobcat yeah that's how
they're made i died for your sins
you'll never hear the end of it um
that's funny he's got like a dealer hat
on because he also loved to gamble
um yeah well that's crap train craps
will do that to you
anyway uh he realizes these people want
to come to see me goes there's got to be
some money in this tarzan thing
so um there are some school teachers
that boarded with john and bessie dubois
who were the people at the restaurant
talked about the pie yeah um so he would
go there and eat once in a while
quote he would order a pie and he'd eat
the whole thing right in front of me so
he would just sit down and eat a whole
[ __ ] pie all the time sure
but i mean when you like when your work
is what
his like you can just do anything and
you're and honestly if
all you yeah it's like if you're
constantly working out you just eat tons
yeah
you just do yes um but
so he started remembering michael phelps
olympic diet yes
whereas like you're like i think you've
got the number wrong no he needs like 8
000 calories a day yeah
of mcdonald's you're like what um so he
he starts helping the teachers that
board with the dubois with
great math papers at night he's grading
math papers at night
he's really great these are all a's i
don't know math so much
i left school at eighth grade
[Laughter]
it's probably because they were ladies
and he he wants to be around ladies but
he's quote painfully awkward around the
ladies yeah but he's because he's used
to like
he i mean you know he's like his life is
animals yeah his life is not that's why
farmers only got
created that's right that's exactly why
farmers only yeah
people are like i'm talking to cows all
day i don't know how to relate to a
female
so so how's your corn crop this year
ma'am
uh that's not i live like near a mom do
you expect a lot of harvest
no i i i work in a barbies
oh uh you have the meats yes we have the
meats
i on my farm also acquire multiple meats
but it is before they are
killed and cut i am okay
sex would be something i'm for i'm
running okay
yeah i'm yeah running far
faster farewell yes take care okay
well that's why i don't come to town yes
yeah so a local fishing boat starts
bringing
tourists up there to see him get a look
okay
people on vacation boys boy scout groups
start making the trip up there in 1937
and like staying
for a couple days it's like you know boy
scouts get away sure
um and then the next year trapper built
cages
and puts animals in them okay and he
makes a sign that reads
trapper nelson's jungle zoo and garden
here we go
uh and now he puts in a docking fee
and an admission fee okay he has the
alligator
the capitalist snake bit him that's
right he has alligator pits
he sells tortoise shells he sells
pineapples and fruits
he sells orchids like he's got a whole
thing going on
he kids would come and wrap the indigo
snake around the kid's neck as part of a
show like right show and tell or
whatever
he basically has an operating zoo right
a guy who went there as a child said
quote i can still remember people buying
baby alligators in little boxes made out
of palmetto leaves
can we just take a moment of silence for
the genocide of baby gators
who clearly are no longer with us and i
mean
imagine giving a child a baby alligator
then what then where does the story go
well
yeah i mean cool beginning yeah terrible
ending oh but there's
yeah there's no doubt that like i mean
you know it's
it's not a durable these things grow oh
they grow quickly you'd be like
bye it's the same thing like when people
would get like
monkeys you'd be like yeah okay now what
now what you had you're fun
yeah now you got a wild animal in your
home yeah
uh he he built the driveway using sand
for people to drive in
um there are so many people running over
snakes that he had to put up a sign that
said attention don't run over
snakes okay wow people like there's a
lot of speed bumps to get on this
property well people would see the
snakes and purposely right oh it's
hilarious let's kill all these animals
nature's ours for the taking so he's
always putting on a show
a girl was visiting when trapper saw a
large alligator swimming by
the dock he didn't say anything he just
jumped in the water and then rode the
alligator until it was able to break
free
wait he wait there's an alligator
swimming by the dock yes
is it swimming i mean what is it called
i guess it's swimming yes he jumps on
the alligator's back and then just
rides it until the alligator is able to
get away
until uh get away from what him oh okay
and he was basically saving the woman
from no he was putting on a show he's
showing her there's no
no i can't ride alligators i can write
i'm an alligator writer right
sure okay ladies love that no no i know
that's how i met my third wife
yeah another team jim carr would later
write quote
i was talking to him up by the alligator
pit when we heard shouts
from the pool of alligator as those in
the woods
where in your pit of them there's a
bunch of them right there oh right at
the pit
sorry as those in the water frantically
swam toward the dock
trapper knocked off his pith helmet ran
to the dock and dove in
you know it's serious when the pith
helmet when the path helmet comes off
it's biz
nice time he surfaced just behind the
gator
grabbed its tail pulled it toward him
grabbed its snout and clamped it shut
with his big hand
with much thrashing and splashing he
manhandled
it to the shore and carried it and
lowered it into the gator pit
wow that is not easy to do that is
[ __ ]
crazy crazy that's all crazy it's crazy
it's completely crazy the gator's like
what the [ __ ] is happening the truth is
it's like alligators well they are so
dangerous
they do have a cut like it's not like
i'm not saying i could do anything to
stop an alligator attack well they got
two things they got the tail
and they got the mouse and the mouth and
the tail it's like if you pull their
tail like the hell is going on here this
isn't how we do it i think if you just
hold their mouth shut they're like
but still impossible yeah it's just yeah
it's not what you would do
um a kid started bringing him small
animals oh good
so he's missing the tip of his thumb and
tell kids quote one time a boy
brought me a rattlesnake and a sack and
when i reached in to grab it by the neck
i missed and it bit me right there so
you tell kids that okay
he said it had to be cut off but
witnesses who were there said he had
sliced he did get bit that way but then
he sliced it open and sucked the venom
out and then he kept talking to the kids
so he's doing like a show
thing excuse me kids i don't want to
interrupt let me just
take a quick rip of this venom anyway
nature is intoxicating but after a
little while
he became light-headed and started
falling over good well i guess drinking
it isn't the right idea either
i can't drive a better bit of venom uh
they rushed him to the hospital uh where
he where he was for
the doctor needed to hear the story five
more times he was there for six days
six days no one knows why the thumb tip
was cut off it could have been something
else but that was his story
sure um by 1940 the rich people
who stayed at the jupiter island club
started hearing about trapper
oh have you heard about this guy he's
wonderful he's
unbelievable he's basically an unkempt
ape man who lives in the middle of
nowhere he's got a sandy driveway with a
bunch of snakes
i was telling darcy we've got to head up
there
you know you've got to see things like
this when they're abound you know
i love nature just as long as i don't
have to be around it
no keep me on the boat oh
the founder of the club started bringing
boatloads of people up
uh the founder's son quote there he'd be
in his shorts and pith helmet usually
with a couple of black snakes draped
around him so it's exactly what they
wanted to see
so but yeah no do you think he knows
they're coming or yeah
okay he knows okay um now these are
fancy people the club owner
would entertain guests like catherine
hepburn
uh the heavyweight champion i love all
your alligators
i said i love your snakes too
also heavyweight champ gina toony now
hey you got
these animals did you need me to box
let's
can we punch a snake or whatever maybe
i'll go and then beat up the water
this is a good practice right we hit the
we hit the
[Music]
alligators
all right all right all right champ all
right champ all right we're going we're
right here
put the blanket over him chad's not
ready to talk anymore if we put the
blanket over he thinks it's night he
goes to bed
sleepy here we go it's night time out
here
toonie said trapper's hands were quote
that his own hands were quote like a
ladies alongside trappers
okay so you're talking about a
heavyweight so many rings and bracelets
i don't know what it is every time i put
it right near there it just
look at the nails so now fancy people
are talking about
this guy trapper living in florida
in the jungle in new york london paris
sure it's like he's like a thing that's
not to get it look it's scary he's in
the middle of nowhere he doesn't even
give a [ __ ]
he's a wonderful wonderful it's
unbelievable he's eating all the things
we found delicacies you know
weird eggs what don't we eat huh
it didn't hurt that he wrestled
alligators and was super good looking
right
and read every day the wall street
journal
oh he do what who is every day he read
the wall street journal what the hell is
going on
well he noticed there was development
happening in real estate stuff so he's
if you open your own like weird
menagerie you're not normally the guy
who's like i don't know where the stonks
what's the s p doing so the ladies are
super in a trapper
some ladies uh like president
monroe's like great granddaughter or
something like they would
cruise up there and stay with them for a
couple days
um they always said she came back with a
smile on her face meaning he showed me
the special
she got a raccoon you know what i mean
trapper's camp became a place that local
teens could make money
okay so they would sell him fish for two
cents a pound
young lewis freeman found an albino
possum
that that he quickly bought glenn mayo
sold him rattlesnakes for a buck a foot
uh okay sure yeah just like joanne
fabrics
ellis roebuck sold him turtles for 25
cents each which he ate
he did other stuff but he ate he ate the
turtles i'm not crazy about this turtle
diet wrinkle
yeah bessie dubois quote he got so he
couldn't eat regular food anymore
i mean he was so darn used to raw possum
and such that his palate couldn't
raw take it does it just doesn't seem
like the animal you want to be eating
wrong i
just it's not that you'd want to be
eating any anything raw
there's this thing in wisconsin i forget
exactly what it is but it's like they
every year's house every year they have
to put out
a reminder that you should not be eating
raw ground beef
and in sandwiches but people in
wisconsin i was raised on it it's good
that people are just eating like raw
beef what yeah
yeah how ah you know you know how you
know how this country is again
what are we gonna do it's just this is
it this is it
this is where we live christ just lean
in it's over you don't have much time
the casino's closing
just have some [ __ ] fun with the
house money in 1938 a boxing
promoter uh from nearby uh he was also a
fighter reporter he came to trapper
with a fight offer okay soon to fight
was being promoted between
the wild man of the lord we want your
odor to fight deodorant
of the loxahatchee and an old texas
texas boxer named tiger long
okay the palm beach post called trapper
a half mountain man and half
mr america okay they wrote fake stories
about him running barefoot to west palm
beach every day for training
in reality he was just punching a a
flower sack filled with sand
near his cabin i would take that story i
mean that's a good story yeah you don't
need to do too much
uh the fight turned out to be very quick
quote he fainted
once with his left hand and when trapper
dropped his glove the guy popped him
right on the button
trapper was knocked out and retired from
boxing he
dropped i mean what boxer's first move
is to lose the glove
oh no no i don't think he lost the guy
no he didn't he just dropped his level
you put his glove down oh he dropped oh
okay i get you i think
i thought it slipped off and you're like
hey i thought these were tied up
so trapper started having trouble with a
neighbor named
hj hardy miller uh
he was getting more and more upset that
cars and hikers were crossing
his land to get to trapper's zoo sure
he's like i didn't i didn't know i
my neighbor was going to be a zoo guy
yeah i'm out in the jungle i didn't
realize there'd be a zoo guy
on top of that some of hardy's goats
kept getting trapped
in trapper's snares sure so hardy
blocked
a bridge that led to trapper's place
with logs
okay i love the old timey warding is
just
like when you know blogs yeah logs will
do it
good luck to you and your goddamn car
i've got lumber in my corner
well looks like someone logged up your
bridge what you gonna do now
trapper checkmate logs
chopper removes the logs no damn it i
forgot you could move i
the fatal flaw was i could move it there
but never thought about it being removed
you can move it both ways yeah yeah they
go yeah
it's movable for all parties yeah they
don't get stuck there they
take them right out they are movable yes
so after that hardy put up a barbed wire
friends across his property
trap or remove that turns out fence is
very similar to lumber can also
be moved then he put a huge pile of
palmetto roots
good luck with this what are you gonna
do move it
i don't think so he moved it oh damn it
what can't he move that i could move so
hardy set the bridge on fire
aha ye can't go backwards and
undo fire
trapper asked the county to fix it they
refused
so he fixed the bridge as best he could
and then
soon after there was a massive explosion
that shook houses
six miles away in jupiter hardy's
goat house had been blown up parts of
goat were all over the place
ah oh well so
hardy goes and gets the sheriff's
deputies and
uh shows them the crime scene so if you
look around here you'll see a lot of
goat heads legs and inside pieces again
this is all
i believe relative to the explosion it
seems all related
and now i'm not a goat man but could it
have been a goat fight
ah a goat what fought a goat farting you
think did all this
no that's right no clearly not i mean
that's why some of them are charred
there was an explosion i saw it there's
no two ways about it could they have
done it in them
did the goats have uh
i could explosive a plastic explosion
i'll stop you right now
these are goats they are not yeah i know
they like to eat anything
sure but that doesn't mean they're
explosive they're not fireworks these
are goats
did you did you feed them dynamite i did
not
i said that look that you're trying to
find out why they exploded on my end
makes no sense i would not explode the
goats they were my ghosts
i'm just saying it looks by the way it
looks like
the way the goats are blown up it looks
like the explosives may have been
inside of them yeah that's right he's
about to say it looks like maybe one of
your goats was a bomb with fur yes
or whatever it is that they have on it
what is it
hair yeah i guess hair would probably be
yeah well i'm telling you that i did not
light any goats on fire no goats there's
no goat bomb
this is simply i would be great if you
went an interviewed trapper the guy
who's insane who lives next door
whose bridge i burned down sure well
i'll tell you when you said goat bomb
my mind really got a cranking and i'm
gonna have to look into goat bombs
great good great work well they
they can explode no i've been so
clear with you that well you did say go
bomb which is not a phrase
he blew up my goats he blew my goats up
this man next door named trapper
with catcher's mitts for hands blew my
goats up
because i burned his bridge because i
hate him now are you talking about
tarzan
yes yes trapper tarzan vince
everybody loves tarzan i'm aware god
damn it
okay we'll see you later i don't think
you should be going
so trapper is arrested on suspicion of
using
dynamite illegally we're going to need
to get elephant handcuffs and he's put
in jail but then sheriffs look for
evidence
they search his place they they can't
find any evidence look we can't find any
evidence plus we're out of cheese we
gotta let him go
he he goes to trial and they find him
not guilty there's just no proof
whatsoever
so i mean
wouldn't you be like the proof is duh he
did it
chopper starts buying land uh it's very
cheap less than ten dollars an acre
swampland is going for two or three
dollars during the depression
people could pay their taxes so they had
to sell their land yeah and he's just
amassing tons of land
this is what we call our business model
in this country that's right
he was friends with the judge who sends
his brother to
life in prison now of course he's
friends with that guy you know we should
keep in touch
it's not great but let's keep in touch
the judge was one of his fishing buddies
um he came up and played in a regular
saturday night poker game at trappers
trapper wouldn't play in the game
he was like the house what a weird role
it's like showing up to a pickup game
being like i'll ref it's i don't know
all right i'll be the ref i got a
whistle i'm cool
um a bunch of legal types from the
courtroom and courthouse
they would come up to his place and play
on saturdays
um so a lot of people think judge
chillingworth gave him land he also
would compete with chillingworth to buy
land like there were two guys trying to
buy up a bunch of land
his brother better never find out about
this relation he already wants to kill
them both
yeah uh world war ii breaks out and
trapper wants to avoid
the draft and being having to go to war
and he thought
he found a way when he met lucille g
he thought marrying would keep him from
being drafted
well i mean it's a pick a war
[Laughter]
now a lot of friends a lot of his
friends did not like
lucille because they thought she was
after his mom did anyone say like hey
just because you're married doesn't mean
you won't be drafted nobody jumped in
ever with it apparently no one
no it's not that no it's not how it
works
uh so he gets drafted in 1940
boy i'm married
[ __ ] in the military he was reprimanded
for cutting his military trousers into
shorts
you got ape man here he's not gonna
listen
i can't confine these thoughts i mean of
all the meticulousness you feel when you
hit when you get like into basic
training the next day to be like i'm
gonna turn my pants into shorts it's
like
they're they're not wired to fathom what
they probably didn't notice
they're probably like we can't actually
see what he did it's so egregious
we are unable to fathom and process what
he's done
now lucille was supposed to take care of
champ and animals what the hell
yeah but it's not like your neighbor's
fish locals said she was mainly focused
on entertaining men
from camp murphy which was nearby so
she's just [ __ ] all the soldiers
she's supposed to be feeding the animals
now i'm not sure where chapter trapper
was but he got hurt exercising
and um and then they sent him
to camp murphy so he's now he's nearby
i just had sex with my wife but she said
it was cheating but
when he when he gets sent to can't
murray lucille's gone he finds out she's
gone
and just has left the animal she left
she ran off with an army colonel
um so trapper keeps going awol to take
care of his animals which is
yeah so he keeps getting in trouble um
the army
then like they see value in him like he
is
a jungle dude they see value as far as
him being a soldier or someone no like a
jungle guy they see
value in whatever he is but meaning they
feel like because of his name and his
notoriety he's good for the army or like
there's another play here
well i think they think he's good for
that but they also think like this guy
knows the jungle he knows
right things that normal soldiers do
okay right yeah right we've got tarzan
you can wear shorts now a boy
[Music]
it's fine they create a
whole new job for trapper
that's never been before it's mp scout
military police scout so for the rest of
his time in the army
he is he is outside the base
around it looking for spies near the
base that's just like
it seems like a really loophole just
super loopholy and weird like they
didn't know like they
recognized like he had a value but they
had no
application for it so they were like you
will find spies that aren't animal spies
see if any of the birds are trying to
figure out what's going on with us
so um he eventually gets out of the army
and so now every i don't know if he was
doing this while
he was in the military after but anyway
this is now
what his zoo camp places is
is two guest cabins a hundred foot long
boat house
we're gonna stay in the zoo a diving
board three
row boats for rent a new parking lot
a metal roofed chickie hunt a chicky
hunt
chicky hunt is like this hut a chicky oh
yeah
that's what i say hunt chicky hut that's
it's the like grass covered roof thing
yeah um and a pistol range in case you
want to do some shooting
sure okay so he has now full on
now he's got a full it's a thing it's a
thing it's a thing
um boy scouts would come and stay above
the chicky hut at night
like a area up there sure he would take
the ladder away so they couldn't get out
and sneak around
at night okay great so your boys are
just not a fire hazard
sure no not at all no and certainly yeah
i mean how kids are they never change
their minds
um it gets still every morning you get
up and shop firewood now that meant he
was
creating tons of firewood that was not
being used
so it was purely an exercise well you
could buy firewood sure and i'm sure he
used a little bit but he was making more
than
was being sold and used it's just not
often that you hear
someone's producing too much firewood so
after a while he had such a massive pile
of firewood someone called it quote
a freight train without wheels so there
is just a map
there's a wood primer he's got to start
putting them together
is this how lincoln logs started this is
exactly how it started
so uh alligators now became a protected
species because the population wasn't
declined because people were doing stuff
like giving away babies and
dragging them out of the water and
riding them yeah right yeah
keeping them in pits having pits
so trapper now spent time trying to get
gators to
come and hang around as river banks so
tourists would see them like he would
hang possums from trees so they would
never but there was food there to eat
right for visitor excitement he would
sometimes
cut off the head of a gopher tortoise
drink its blood and then lecture about
how great
wildlife nutrition was
[Music]
if i go anywhere and the person who i've
paid admission to
is vampiring blood out of an animal
i'm calling it no it's it's like a
jungle ozzy osbourne he's [ __ ]
biting tortoise heads up that's right
he's just delicious towards his head
it's lovely it's just like what kid
wants to see that
hey so um i'm gonna take my son home now
uh this is crazy and not what we wanted
so i'll see you later guy what the [ __ ]
just happened over here
what if he ate the head or spit it out
oh any i mean no matter what like just
someone drinking blood
imagine just watching so much just drink
blood
i just don't this is a problem
what no no
he had uh one gator that he really liked
named stumpy
stumpy was missing a foot and a lot of
his tail been bitten off by another
gator
probably by trapper yeah i ate his tail
uh one time stumpy went missing and so
trapper spent
days hunting him down to get him to come
back come here boy
come home come home
the wealthy famous people were still
coming in 1940 gop
presidential candidate wendell wilkie
came gary cooper
dupont's kennedys like it's the the
top of the top yeah they're coming
that's amazing duponts
yeah all the locals were gossiping about
ladies who went up river and spent the
weekend with tarzan
in the 1950s he's just he's hustling
he's shipping animals to zoos and
wholesalers he's selling
pelts to sears roebuck he sold mail
loader orchids
he grew sugarcane and would sell pieces
to visitors he'd rent row boats
fishing poles you could buy baby
alligators and raccoons and firewood
they'll buy baby alex yeah firewood for
sure i'll give you firewood can i get uh
i'll pay you to take five can i get uh
just a
ten bucks of firewood and three raccoons
and uh i
guess any baby gators you want to think
about yeah throw a couple of baby games
all right we're here to go oh that'd be
cool all right that'll be 9 15. pull it
around to the second window
so during a poker game he was hosting
trapper was losing
and he got up from the table and walked
out the back door
and returned with a handful of crumpled
up
dirty bills he told a friend quote oh
i've got money hidden all over my
pineapple patch
is that like there's there's certain
sentences that you're like i don't know
if it's ever been said like i just don't
think it's ever been said before
he's just bearing in the dirt he's just
got some doll he's just he's not like
putting in bags
dog with bones he just literally has
like
replicated animal behavior on a level
where his bank is just
holes in his pineapple area
um he did help sick or and injured
animals
how much is it i'll be right
250.
[Laughter]
um he would help sick and injured
animals if they needed surgery he would
do it himself
he would also use anesthesia
um he sold skunks for pets after
removing their scent glands
oh that's the that's hor that i've heard
of [ __ ] like that that to me is so
messed up
um this all by the way this guy should
not be removed like should not be the
stink judge of anyone
wow yeah wow
[Laughter]
so all went pretty good until about
1960. the population on jupiter had
tripled between 1945 and 1960.
uh it's being areas being developed
there's oceanfront condos there's gated
golf communities
and suddenly he starts having issues um
as hard to find animals i'm guessing
well as if someone wanted him off the
land
oh okay first came government regulators
hmm
one made him get a 10 000 security bond
to keep
poisonous snakes okay i'm gonna go after
look through the pineapple area for a
little while to get that money
then they had uh then they had him pay
sales tax on visitors fees
and then health inspectors came
[Music]
and told him um our heads are blowing up
so we're just trying to keep our brains
in our bodies
sorry where do you drink the blood uh
over there over there but may i'll just
let it run down me and then people can
lick it off me for a nickel
yeah and there's blood everywhere uh
this is the gut pile
this is varies i mean some of these guts
are three months old some are two months
old
hey do any of you fancy some fresh fish
oh it's right here just put i put the
fish in the chicken area
see how you got all these chicken
breasts that's where i keep the fish
okay so there's a bunch of fish there
okay uh oh what is this you want a piece
of gum
i'm kidding that's a skunk stink maker
fool
how you almost say to stink from a skunk
what is this pile of possums here that's
just pop it's pretty straight forward
it's a pile of possums what's your
question
what are they for well they're just a
pile of possums what do you mean what's
that okay
no i was just a pilot okay i mean for
whatever
but do you need a possum what do you
need a possum body for i don't well you
eat it raw
um you eat the possum raw no yeah yeah
yeah it's like steak tartare but it's
possum tartare
i'm throwing up in my throat oh whoa do
that the throw pile i keep all
i keep all throw up right there do that
i use it for the slip and slide
i let the kids go down through the throw
up slip and slide and then they're going
into the gut pile
oh this is like action park yeah i mean
to each their own but i call it gut
island
so the health inspectors come
and they say the outhouses he had
weren't good enough
so oh and he doesn't imagine someone
saying yeah your outhouse isn't up to
code
your [ __ ] box doesn't work for us
[Music]
so he has no running water but he
installs concrete bathrooms
with running water i mean he literally
he is
legit he he i mean yeah i don't know how
he did that it's not easy that
is it's a project i mean that is
really yes absolutely crazy yes to
figure out plumbing
i mean as a novice or not is yeah fairly
remarkable
um but the toilets run on blood
these are blood
there was a picture i wish i could find
the picture of the bathrooms but there's
a picture of the bathrooms but i can't
find them right now but they're they're
like
it's crazy like that guy actually built
that like that's
[ __ ] nuts um so
obviously they're sticking it to them
right yeah right they're
they're coming after him right so when
he's done building the bathrooms the
health inspector comes out and says well
those aren't good enough
and then they go oh and your sister for
getting rid of animal [ __ ] isn't good
enough and he would basically every
morning
hose the cages down and right which is
basically what they do i don't know
go to like bring a health inspector to a
zoo yeah i know that's what i was
thinking yeah
well it's a lot of a lot of feces here i
found i don't know what that's from
and more people more and more people are
coming but now sometimes not the ones he
wanted
author snyder quote gangs of teenage
boys would foul his traps and sneak up
at night
and taunt the legend of the lokaha
loxahatchee with some sort of right of
manhood
so they were you know they were having
the teenage boys like go do this and
[ __ ] with them this way and
he's now over 50. right and he's still
muscly but he's got a gut he's got
he's working a dad bod now it's not the
same old
yeah dude yes he started changing his
route and days when he would go to town
to throw
off vandals and robbers wow
bessie dubois quote i think a lot of
trouble had to do with him deciding to
rent out his guest cabins to strangers
they attracted a pretty rough crowd
a family member said guests kept getting
drunk and walking on top of the gator
cages
i remember one time a guy lifted the top
and actually fell in i think the gators
were more scared than he was
wow that's a luxurious position to be in
so
now we we've gone from which i guess is
how it always works right
you have uh you know locals and then and
then
tourists and now just [ __ ] idiots
yeah right now that just the idiots are
coming yeah
uh he wrote his brother-in-law quote
have closed my camp to all the public
including the crews
now i feel a lot safer as it was a real
risk
in many ways dealing with the public
so he closed the road gate he took down
the rope swing
and he took down part of the dock and
then he cut down trees
so they blocked boats from coming up the
river wow
he put up a no trespassing sign and
another that read
danger landmines you
like i mean i look yes
it's a great it's a great lie but can we
just start putting those signs up please
it's just the terror look whether it's
real or not i don't feel like vlogging
on land for a little while is that fair
um but also you could just be like
danger
wild everything
snake pit imagine if you saw that
dangerous snake pit i'd be like i'm not
going there
it's so crazy it's dangerous
it's just it's just such a [ __ ] mind
like it's like oh well you kind of
believe it you like well that's
totally that's it's a really good lie
because
it's kind of right on the edge of where
i would put him
like i'd like i'm like i could buy
landmines i could see him doing
landmines
um that's the bathroom oh wow
yeah no joke no joke i mean it's it's
impressive
i mean the dude the dude know how to do
stuff um
so right so now locals are like oh
things have taken a dark turn up there
right like yeah but it's also like i
mean again you
you know he seems like he's been forced
into yeah decisions yeah it wasn't
yeah so he's he's got tons of land right
he's been buying land forever he has
over 1100 acres
oh my god this is come get me this is
prime land i mean right
if you know what jupiter island is now
it's just [ __ ] rich people right
so that but also real estate taxes are
going up
his county tax bill went up 350 in one
year
and that's one way that developers get
your property yeah
um he tried he tries to get a loan he's
trying different places and
he's having a hard time and finally he
gets a five year i've been banking with
the pineapples lately
i don't have a regular bank that problem
he gets a five-year 100 000 loan with a
10 yearly interest wow from
a local businessman named george offutt
it's a shitty loan yeah it's a [ __ ]
shitty loan
he had to pull he had to pay full
interest every six months
or the guy would get all his property
wow
terrible love i'll sign this is pretty
good i like most of it
if he misses one payment the guy gets
his property
now trapper when he gets a loan he
thought it was enough to live on
and keep his land he's like this is
perfect
so he fences in his four mile track of
land
with barbed wire to keep people out okay
and in 1964
he could barely make the first interest
payment that year
he puts up land for sale signs all over
the place
the next interest payment is due on
august 24th and he's 11 000
behind so he makes a deal to sell
200 acres to this real estate group
and then they're like does anyone else
have any claim on this land
and he's like no and then his ex-wife
pops up there's cg and
the lawyers say that there was never a
proper divorce
and she wants her share oh no
so trapper is so [ __ ] mad he wants to
just kill the sale and walk away from it
completely but he can't
yeah now on august 24th
this awful guy is in the courtroom at 1
30.
like two o'clock he's got it if he
doesn't have the money
he could foreclose on all of his land
but trapper trapper's lawyers or whoever
cuts a deal at the last minute with his
guerrillas right yes okay and a couple
uh
tortoises right they cut a deal at the
last minute with his ex-wife
she gets 30 000 and two lots of land
so he sells over 200 acres for 322
thousand
he pays off off it with 15 minutes to
spare
wow that land became the riverbend and
turtle creek country clubs
oh well at least it went to lake that's
a good it's a good like good
good cause yeah like a good cause so
after paying all the people off he had
to pay off
he is left with 63 000 but he has no
debt
the first time ever he's out of debt and
then he starts buying modern appliances
the first time he gets fridges and
freezers and
he starts eating steaks that he bought
from the store oh wow he's still
trapped but one of the problems was davy
crockett was not as popular with kids
anymore
and so [ __ ] skin caps were no longer the
item of the day
you guys like a few of those back you
gotta we got a lot of those we got a lot
we got a lot of back orders on these
this is not good
we over bought and then trapper was
different he's changed quote outsiders
claim to see a dour
slow-moving husk of a man
[Music]
now if you wanted to visit him his even
friends
you had to send a postcard and then he
would have to write you back and then
set up a date that's how i do it that's
the way to do it
yeah this is the best you may just be
that i mean in many ways it would be the
best way
to be you know like just to like people
if you
you get postcards and you get to decide
oh to to not
have to get texts and emails all the
time yeah i mean imagine some guy just
sending you
you know when you get a postcard someone
like yeah just some guy constantly
sending gifts of just uh sup
what's up like like for like for
days on it days it just keeps happening
and then you keep saying stop
seriously stop and the guy just finds an
unlimited amount of these supplements
it's like there's millions of them
it's like there's so
days and days so it's in person is way
more digestible than it is
every time i look at my phone and see
i've missed four gifts
so um so he's also always got a shotgun
nearby
he catches two hunters on a land on his
land with their guns and
says i'll kill you if you come back so
it's sure
he's alone he's [ __ ] yes it's a weird
he's carved out a weird little life yeah
um and and he's and he's living an
existence that isn't
compatible with right the reality of
you know capitalism right i mean it's
it's coming
yeah they they want it they want the
land everyone wants the land
it's yeah whatever so an old friend goes
to see him and he
as he gets close chopper stands out
trapper steps out from behind a tree and
he's holding a shotgun
and his friend says quote trapper it's
me your old friend dick and trapper
says quote i don't have any friends go
away now or i'll start shooting
by 1968 he's getting sick a lot
and this started after he started eating
store-bought food and steaks
well if you're just eating wild food and
then i mean if you if you don't eat
like take i'll give you an example
we're coming back from a tournament
there's no food anywhere i'm [ __ ]
starving
oh boy all that's there is a mcdonald's
oh god we're literally in the middle of
nowhere in the desert
so i go [ __ ] what do i i get here i get
fries
my kid gets um
the nuggets sure and i eat a couple the
nuggets oh my god
and it's my body is literally ravaged
for a week oh my god my like my body's
like what did you do
because i don't eat that kind of stuff
but i'm [ __ ] starving
whatever you know it's good food but
it's great food fast it's not fast food
it's good food fast if you don't eat it
and then you eat it you
know you those people know how bad it is
but if you eat it all the time your
body's like here we go again i'm ready
for
i've been in this war for a while but if
you never eat it and then you eat it
your body's like
what the [ __ ] is this what have you
brought in here
so um so he's getting sick a lot uh
bessie dubois said he quote was always
complaining about gas
said he thought he had colon cancer
dubois would see him because trapper
would use a pay phone at their
restaurant so they're like the only
people are seeing them
now a newbie a new deal is being talked
about to sell his last 857 acres
to jonathan dickinson state park
the deal would allow him to live on a
hundred acres of land
around his cabin and he'd be a
millionaire for the sale
he told friends that he was excited to
travel
so he's caught you know right things are
looking up a little bit um
he's excited to have all the money and
travel but sure but he's still got the
health problems
um he now needs a catheter to pee
yeah he thinks he has prostate cancer
but a doctor looks at him and he's like
you don't
he keeps saying i want to bob cathy
he keeps saying he has cancer but the
doctor's like you don't have cancer
although he won't go to the doctor that
much
so some people say he's miserable but in
letters
he wrote to friends he sounds pretty
pretty content
okay um he knew he was gonna be rich
but he still he still doesn't like the
developers and lawyers
and a few of his neighbors on
july 30th no one's seen him for a week
or so
july 30th 1968 someone goes up there and
finds his body
on the beach face down shotgun is a few
feet behind him oh dear
the shell had gone through his abdomen
and then up and out the back of his head
he had been dead for over a week guinea
hands and raccoons had
picked at the body it's their time it's
payback time yeah
oh he actually is very good blood my
ancestors waited for this
quote what was left of the brain looked
like mushroom soup oh
dave come on some people are going to
eat mushroom soup again what's your
problem
i don't think they are well they were i
should say no they're not it's over
jesus christ the more cream of mushroom
the body is in such bad shape the
pathologist didn't want to move it to do
the autopsy so he
he did it on a picnic table in the
cheeky hut sorry that we have this area
reserved for my niece's
birthday it's okay just go up top okay
soup what sort of cake is that oh
that's mushroom soup yes we'd love a
bite got a whole bowl
um so there's no signs of cancer he
doesn't have cancer okay
uh jury rules it to suicide but once
he he killed himself via abdomen
yeah okay so yeah so
once people hear the verdict there's a
lot of like no right
there's no fingerprints on the gun
there's no footprints in the sand
meaning he didn't go there either his
footprints aren't there and neither
anybody else's
yeah so that means somebody probably
brush it i mean usually or
it could have been he was there for a
week and sure got blown away
um his brother had threatened to kill
him
and he'd been out of jail for a while oh
boy and then
people like why the [ __ ] would this guy
who understands guns so well shoot
himself in the abdomen yeah the abdomen
not even the heart no
abdomen oh i want to die overnight real
pain
a real bad one want to really savor it
but there's a lot of theories the the
developers do it
are also people who
sort of lived off the land and didn't
like him because he
had the property until he had there's
contention with those people
anyway there's lots of theories a woman
named vivian
leblanc went with her young sons to
trappers property to look around
post death yeah on the drive back
her boys were a little too quiet in the
back seat so she looks back and they are
playing with dirty sticks of dynamite
oh god so maybe the goat that's maybe
the dynamite from the goat explosion oh
right right
um the land is sold off six months later
to
the park system okay his ex-wife comes
and demands her share
sure well she's earned it but they
they're like no you already signed a
[ __ ] deal with the last
right gob of money you got but they give
her 5 000 just to go away because
it'll cost that in court fees anyway i
love the
i need more go away some of the land is
developed some becomes the park part of
the park
years later when doing some work on
choppers house park rangers found a
bunch of hidden money
that was a good thing because they were
underfunded it was only a couple
thousand dollars but
um they used it to help fix it up
today's trappers
camp is a main attraction in jonathan
dickinson
state park his original buildings
gardens and cages are still there
wow crazy what a crazy yeah
it's such a weird it's
it's really strange when you're you know
you have this business model that is
so outside of business like it's just
it's strange it's like because even in
this you're hearing about like the
long-term sustainability of this project
it is it's it's unsustainable in many
ways so it is unsustainable it's weird
to
it's but it's also weird to spend half
of your life
sort of outside of society's
you know hands and then spend the second
half of your life
kind of under the gun from them yeah
which is basically
what happens but i mean well yeah i mean
you know i it's an interesting story
because it's
it's a weird life yeah and
and and then you can have freedom doing
what you want
until i mean there are things that are
bad right
killing gators and yeah that's the thing
there's too much and then there's
you know you don't want um [ __ ] just
going into the water
like there are reasonable things but
then also it's like well this is clearly
development wanting that land well the
the truth is that
you know if you had to pick between
having one person
um killing gators and
animals through trapping around there or
you want to have
business developers in the area you
would much rather as far as like
the footprint have just the one guy you
know it is
to some extent it is someone who is
doing all of this killing on their own
with their own devices
and things like that whereas the other
one its goal isn't to kill
it's just part of the model that it will
right so it
just i mean when you when you read about
like florida in particular about
you know some of the panther and bobcat
those numbers it is i mean it it's just
startling how
often we will get a species to the brink
of extinction
and then think oh well we'll just save
it by just you know
putting some together or keeping them
enclosed or
you know for but it's like no man like
you you you have completely
like you start to get to inbreeding and
there are genetic failures and there's
you know problems with like
their hearts because of inbreeding and
all these things and it's like
you know the simpler version is to just
not over [ __ ] with nature
and we really don't seem to think that
as a viable option
every every person is going to keep
building until there's no land left to
build on
everything is going to keep eating
everything around you so when you talk
about like
the overall uh abuse of nature
one guy yeah like i'm sure these animals
didn't have the greatest lives at times
and they were
killed by him and he was [ __ ]
drinking blood and
eating raw possum but again that
is someone who's probably using a lot
more of those resources
directly versus people who are just like
no
animals are just hurdles right and you
know
yeah i mean it's it's a really
interesting sort of
yeah you can't you don't get to you just
don't get to do that
you just don't you don't get to live
that life it's it's
eventually especially i mean you could
probably do it in like up in montana or
something
like a joe exotic florida i think yeah
but not in a
oklahoma not in a tropical sort of
paradise
place you don't they're gonna come for
you they're gonna come for the land
yes for sure i mean that's it's
you know i mean it's like you know it's
like farmers it's like
you know an independent farmer like is
[ __ ] with
on so many different levels like you're
just you're not allowed to just kind of
at this point live on your own and do
your own thing it's
it's just kind of not it's not working
for us anymore
yeah and and look also
you know i am of the opinion that no one
should be
allowed to own land right man shouldn't
be owned
yes and because people like well how is
that well well how did someone get the
land first
well literally how did how did how did
how did literally
just like it's mine yeah i mean you know
california there's this family that's
incredibly rich because some guy just
came here
in the [ __ ] 1800s and bought all the
land next to the rivers bought it from
who or even if you think of like the
resnicks
like we've talked about that before like
how did they get like
80 of the water it was just like the
timing was just
right and then you were able to buy the
water
yeah it's just you know ownership of
resources
is totally mind-bending and it's unknown
it's completely untenable and instead of
fighting that
we just go like well i want to buy as
much as i can now because we're all in
the same state of parliament
yeah we're all going to because they've
all put us here because they've told us
these are the rules this is the game and
we're like well
instead of asking any questions the best
i just better roll the dice
yeah yeah i mean basically yeah and that
is
and it uh and what's good is it's going
to work out
and i like that part of it that feels
good to me it's working out right now
it's going great
i mean we should be building up not
sideways
yeah that's so everything should just be
going up i mean imagine if you lived in
cities but then right outside your city
was just wilderness
like everything would be [ __ ] awesome
like you'd be like i'm in my house oh
now i can just literally go a mile
and be in pure wilderness in a lot of
ways that's like what
it seems like people are actually
craving i mean one of the things that
the pandemic really
i think did do to people was make people
recognize
that you know taking a beat and being
like yeah my
job sucks my pace sucks i miss nature i
mean that just seems like a lot of
people
are getting there and um you know it's
it's your time to really want to
preserve and save for sure
yeah um sources
do it wait where'd this go come on [ __ ]
whoa language oh that's not the right
one
oh my god i can't aaron we gotta wrap
this is just ridiculous
good good good good good gareth oh yeah
i wrote a lot of this one
um it's in my book called
trapper keeper uh uh so the main source
was
by james snyder life and death
on the loxahatchee the story of trapper
nelson
nelson um also
article trapper nelson a remembrance
and uh the li the strange life and
mysterious death of a panther
panther trapping gator wrestling well
man
malinowski um on narratively malinowski
and then the palm beach post had a
really long article on him
well life well lived seems like that's
what we deal with here we get like
you know you get like half the life and
then the
second half of the life is like yeah man
is the the
the the lives always
completely change like there's a glory
period and there's always a [ __ ]
just downfall it's just it's
it's crazy it's just the way it is yeah
it's weird
it certainly
worries you well at least at least the
billionaires are going up into space
that's all that really matters yeah
they're building up
up up and away god how many people want
just want one of those rockets to blow
up though i mean honest to god i just
wish
yeah the way that i mean
yeah like the way like i i'm not worried
about the ego of jeff bezos and i don't
know how much of it gets to him or how
much of it gets to zuckerberg
but you know if those guys were paying
any attention
they would be like gosh everyone thinks
we're real dick
we all hate you they don't [ __ ] like
we all hate you yeah you don't care
you've like
you've bought enough land so that we
can't get to you you're real
trappers hidden in your own little like
mark zuckerberg is like forcing hawaii
to sell them land
all this [ __ ] but just know we [ __ ]
hate you
so much nobody likes you riding on your
[ __ ] surfboard with an american flag
you [ __ ] douche tool
god damn and you know what the amazing
thing about that is he is on lake tahoe
which is
this place that used to be a really cool
sort of getaway and now it has been
since the pandemic started overrun by
rich [ __ ]
and there there is a great example no
there there's so many places are going
like these
rich pricks are you know it
ah yeah how do we always land here
that's fun and then by the end i'm like
i hate everything about us
well all right we sign uh we sign gators
yeah well gatorson woo
you